bonjour à tous dans quelques instants
vous allez suivre l'examen en séance
publique du projet de loi sur le
harcèlement sexuel
un texte qui arrive en procédure
accélérée au sénat puisque je vous le
rappelle le texte
la précédente loi sur le harcèlement
sexuel a été abrogée par le conseil
constitutionnel en mai et du coup les
victimes du harcèlement sexuel sont
aujourd'hui face à un vide juridique
avec nous le sénateur socialiste de la
gironde alain anziani
vous êtes rapporteur pour la commission
des lois sur ce texte
vous étiez également l'auteur d'une
proposition de loi sur le sujet tout
d'abord première question le texte vous
paraît-il satisfaisant aujourd'hui
notamment sur le plan de la sécurité
juridique
oui je crois que c'était un texte
nécessaire et rapidement nécessaire et
qu'il devait veiller à un équilibre
d'un côté il faut respecter ce que nous
dit conseil constitutionnel est ce que
nous dit le conseil constitué c'est que
nous avions fait le législateur avait
fait une loi flou et donc inapplicable
et puis en même temps il faut aussi
qu'on prenne en compte la souffrance des
victimes qui est je trouve trop minorée
aujourd'hui trop sous-estimée et donc
faire aussi un texte qui permettent de
couvrir tous les formes de harcèlement
sexuel et je crois que nous avons abouti
à partant du texte du gouvernement mais
également des propositions loi un texte
qui arriva à cet équilibre
certaines associations estiment
cependant que ce texte est complexe et
que cela peut créer d'autres problèmes
complexes je ne crois pas la matière est
complexe
la pratique judiciaire est difficile le
texte lui-même il essaye de simplifier
d'un côté il va distinguer le
harcèlement par répétition
et puis de leur côté l'accent
harcèlement par acte unique qui pour
l'instant n'étaient pas admis dans le
code pénal et le harcèlement par acte
unique s'avère tellement fort c'est
quelqu'un qui dit à une autre personne
si tu couche pas avec moi je ne tends
bouge pas et ce cas là n'était pas
prévue du façon précise dans le code
pénal ce avait été déjà d'ailleurs
un objet de discussion en 1992 au moment
de la création ça n'avait pas été retenu
et depuis finalement les tribunaux
s'interroge et parfois longuement pour
savoir si l'acte unique n'est pas ou pas
donc cela on tranche la question et ont
fait à la fois le harcèlement par acte
unique à l'art ce moment par répétition
et puis aussi je crois qu'on aggrave les
peines et une souvent une controverse on
aggrave les peines avant c'était un an
et quinze mille euros là dans les toutes
les formes donc dans les deux formes de
harcèlement sexuel
et bien c'est sera désormais deux ans et
30000 euros donc on va aggraver la peine
et en cas de circonstances aggravantes
ou passe à 3 ans et 45000 euros
est ce que le texte est également
davantage dans les clous je pourrais
dire
d'un point de vue communautaire le texte
a une forte inspiration communautaire on
a repris vous savez qu'il ya cinq
directives et donc dans cinq directives
il ya de nouvelles orientations avait
que deux notions majeurs d'une part les
tout ce qui porte atteinte à la dignité
et la dignité va être au centre
évidemment de nos discussions et puis
d'autre part tout ce qui crée un
environnement hostile intimidant alors
ce cette notion d'environnement il ya
beaucoup de débats est ce que en droit
français cette notion d'environnement
qui nous vient finalement du droit anglo
saxon et va être compréhensibles par nos
tribunaux ou pas et vous verrez tout à
l'heure que c'est un objet du débat avec
une proposition qui consiste à
substituer aux termes d'environnement le
terme de situation il ya également une
demande qui est fait depuis longtemps et
de manière récurrente par les
associations c'est celle de la crèche la
création d'un observatoire des violences
faites aux femmes
quel est votre avis sur le sujet et
comment s'expliquer que cela n'ait pas
encore été fait alors en réalité il ya
des jeunes observatoire qui n'est pas
consacré uniquement aux violences faites
aux femmes
et donc nous nous allons proposer et je
pense que madame la ministre sera
d'accord pour que cet observatoire
élargie soit un objet est aussi
s'interroge sur les violences faites aux
femmes
c'est le choix est simple soit on a un
observatoire aujourd'hui on élargit son
objet soit on crée encore un autre
observatoire ce n'est pas la
multiplication la crête des
observatoires qui va permettre de mieux
couvrir mais il faut effectivement que
chacun soit plus sensible à cette
question là donc part de l'observation
par des statistiques ça mais aussi
d'ailleurs par une culture judiciaire
moi ce que je constate c'est que vous
n'avez que 55 à 70 condamnation par an
pour des faits de harcèlement sexuel
aurait évidemment vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup plus de cas donc là aussi une
pédagogie avoir auprès de magistrats
les premiers problème c'est que les
victimes ne portent pas plainte d'abord
la plainte est difficile mais pas
uniquement pour le harcèlement est
poussé en matière d'infractions
sexuelles
pour le viol c'est le cas pour
l'agression sexuelle la plainte est
toujours douloureuse en elle même pour
la victime
et puis ensuite après vous avez un
phénomène particulier
c'est la preuve dans le cas du
harcèlement sexuel souvent il y à lui il
y à elle en général c'est plutôt une
femme dans ce sens là et c'est souvent
la parole de lui contre la parole de m
et donc une difficulté pour la victime
de faire la preuve ce qui est abouti à
ce que la moitié des procédures engagées
aujourd'hui non pas de suite ne donnent
pas lieu à des condamnations
donc on a ici aussi dans ce texte de
favoriser l'apport de la preuve
mais n'oublions pas aussi que nous
sommes des législateurs et donc nous
devons aussi tenir compte de des grands
principes du droit pénal et notamment
évidemment le principe de la présomption
d'innocence nous le revendiquons en
toute infraction nous sommes obligés
aussi de le revendiquer pour cette
infraction là mais essayons d'améliorer
quand même la preuve à apporter
merci beaucoup à laon diani pour cet
entretien tout de suite dont direction
l'hémicycle pour l'examen en séance
publique du projet de loi sur le
harcèlement sexuel bien donc l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion du projet de
loi relatif au harcèlement sexuel
madame la garde des sceaux madame la
ministre de la justice madame la
ministre des droits des femmes porte
parole du gouvernement
mes chers collègues à la suite de
l'invalidation par le conseil
constitutionnel de la disposition de
notre code pénal réprimant le
harcèlement sexuel le sénat a mené un
travail approfondi sur ce sujet pendant
la suspension des travaux
cette proposition de loi ont été
déposées et un groupe de travail
associant la commission des lois la
commission des affaires sociales et la
délégation aux droits des femmes a
établi un rapport après avoir procédé à
de très nombreuses auditions
je remercie le gouvernement d'avoir pris
en compte ces initiatives sénatoriales
en déposant le projet de loi relatif au
harcèlement sexuel sur le bureau notre
assemblée le texte établi par la
commission des lois constitue une
synthèse des différents travaux menés et
je tiens à féliciter le questeur à la
diane hi rapporteur du projet de loi
ainsi que l'ensemble de nos collègues
qui se sont impliqués sur ce sujet dans
la discussion générale
la parole est un madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
madame la présidente dominique
monsieur madame la présidente monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mesdames les présidents de commission
monsieur madame le solaire à porter
madame la présidente permettez que je
vois dans votre dans le fait que nos
travaux soient placés sous votre
présidence un signal particulier auquel
nous sommes partis au mans sans cible
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter au nom
du gouvernement un texte de loi un
projet de loi dans le caractère urgent
et important n'échappe à personne
ce caractère urgent provient du fait
qu'il convient de mettre un terme le
plus rapidement possible à la situation
résultant de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui statuent ans une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité à le 4 mai dernier
abroger les délit de harcèlement sexuel
cette abrogation entre immédiatement en
vigueur a créé de fait un vide juridique
qui nous oblige
placé devant cet impératif de nécessité
juridique
nous sommes convenus de la célérité avec
laquelle il convenait d'agir
et pour cela nous avons veillé à trois
principes le premier la nécessité de
mettre un terme à cette impunité
conjoncturelle qui laisse sans réponse
pénale appropriée les faits de
harcèlement sexuel en sachant que la
nouvelle loi ne peut être rétroactive
puisque elle est plus sévère que les
dispositions qui ont été abrogés et vous
savez que seules les lois +12 peuvent
être rétroactive ambre au pénal
le deuxième principe auquel nous sommes
soumis consisté à porter une attention
particulière aux victimes dans la mesure
où depuis le 4 mai les faits nouveaux de
l'enseignement actuel ne peuvent être
poursuivis par la voie pénale et que ne
leur reste que la voie civile dont nous
savons qu'elle est assez peu
satisfaisante en troisième point nous
avons veillé à la solidité juridique du
texte que nous voulons nous avons
souhaité vous présenter pour définir
l'infraction
compte tenu des motifs
exposée par le conseil constitutionnel
pour justifier cette abrogation
d'ailleurs comme vous le disiez madame
la présidente le fina a parfaitement
saisi l'urgence et l'importance de cette
nécessité de pallier ce vide juridique
puisque dès les semaines qui ont suivi
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
cette proposition de loi ont été
déposées et votre commission des lois
votre commission des affaires sociales
ainsi que la délégation aux droits des
femmes ont constitué un groupe de
travail qui s'est aussitôt attelée à
trouver des solutions les solutions les
mieux adaptées
je veux donc prendre le temps de saluer
cette contribution essentielle du sénat
par la qualité des propositions de loi
qui ont été présentés la qualité des
auditions que vous avez conduite par
l'état des lieux qui en a résulté
nous avons pu en un court délai poser
les bases de notre réflexion la
commission des lois adoptées à
l'unanimité en sa séance du 27 juin
le projet de loi intégrant les
modifications appréciable provenant des
rapporteurs
monsieur alain anziani rapporteur de la
commission des lois saisie sur le fond
madame christiane demontès rapporteur de
la commission des affaires sociales et
madame brigitte gonthier maurin pour la
délégation aux droits des femmes
c'est donc sur ce texte enrichi que
porteront nos débats ce jour le
président de la république s'était
engagé durant la campagne à traiter ce
sujet en priorité et c'est effectivement
grandes priorités que le gouvernement
sont est saisi et tient à la fois du
symbole et de la volonté politique que
ce soit le premier texte examiné devant
votre haute assemblée je le disais ce
texte est important car il est question
de dignité de la personne
les femmes proposent les gros bataillons
des victimes de ce délit sans gêne sans
constituer la totalité des victimes
mais il demeure que le harcèlement
sexuel est avant tout un harcèlement
deux ans comme a pu le souligner le
sociologue michel bozon
ce qui renvoie à la fois à la
différenciation et aux représentations
sociales
le sujet est universel
un beau film récente de mohamed diame
les femmes du bus 678 nous rappelle que
ce délit n'est reconnue en egypte depuis
trois ans trois femmes exposent exposés
à des formes diverses de harcèlement et
d'agressions sexuelles ont répondu
réagit différemment selon leur
appartenance sociale selon leur
éducation selon tempérament mais de ces
combats disparates de disperser ont
convergé à converger une même volonté de
modifier à la fois la loi et les
mentalités dans la société
une enquête nationale ici en france en
2000 fixé à 1,9 pourcentage de femmes se
déclarant victime de harcèlement dans
les 12 derniers mois
l'étude la plus récente sur le sujet
diligentée en 2007 par le conseil
général de seine saint denis qui a
interrogé plus de 1500 femmes indiquent
que 22% d'entre elle disait avoir été
victime de harcèlement ou d'une
agression sexuelle
durant les 12 derniers mois
ces faits concernent toutes les
catégories sociales et les femmes
exposées ont des profils divers
étudiante employés cadres professions
libérales
c'est pour cela que votre délégation des
droits des femmes parle à juste titre de
l'aide sociale
le texte que nous présentons n'est ni
misérabiliste ni victime m
et ce en dépit de l'impact y que nous
éprouvons pour les victimes
nous connaissons les effets dévastateurs
du harcèlement nous savons à quel point
il peut détruire la personnalité
l'estiment de soit réduit à la capacité
à se projeter dans des projets
personnels ou professionnels mais nous
connaissons aussi la combativité des
femmes qui refusent de se laisser
écraser et nous pensons que mieux vaut
les bien armé que les mâles servir je
vous propose un rapide historique de
l'infraction
le délit de harcèlement sexuel est entré
dans notre droit pénal le 1er mars 94
lors de l'adoption du nouveau code pénal
il résultait d'un amendement introduit
en 91 à l'assemblée nationale par madame
yvette roudy et monsieur gérard vise la
rédaction initiale de l'article 222 33
du code pénal réprime est le fait de
harceler autrui en usant d'ordre de
menaces ou de contrainte
dans le but d'obtenir des faveurs de
nature sexuelle par une personne abusant
de l'autorité que lui confèrent ses
fonctions
la loi du 17 juin 1998 relative à la
prévention et la répression des
infractions sexuelles descendu par
madame elisabeth guigou garde des sceaux
modifié à la définition en y ajoutant
les pressions graves
le gouvernement et le législateur visait
à réprimer des comportements qui quoique
sans être d ordre des contraintes ou des
menaces constituaient des atteintes
insupportables
la nouvelle rédaction de l'article 222
33 du code pénal réprime et ainsi d'un
an d'emprisonnement et 15 mille euros
d'amendé le fait de harceler autrui dans
le but d'obtenir des faveurs de nature
sexuelle à côté du harcèlement propre
mendier le code du travail interdisait
et punissaient les discriminations
commises contre les salariés ayant subi
ou refusé de subir des agissements de
harcèlement sexuel
ces discriminations et est puni d'un an
d'emprisonnement et 3750 euros d'amendé
à la suite d'une erreur malencontreuse
intervenu lors de la recodification du
code du travail opéré en 2007 entre en
vigueur le 1er janvier 2008
ces peines ont été supprimés le 4 mai
donc le conseil constitutionnel je vous
le disais saisi par la cour de cassation
d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité a considéré que les
éléments constitutifs de l'infraction
n'était pas suffisamment défini et que
l'article 222 33 méconnaissait le
principe de légalité des délits et des
peines le conseil a en conséquence
déclaré cette partie que contraire à la
constitution et à préciser que cette
censure était applicable immédiatement à
toutes les affaires non encore
définitivement jugée
le 10 mai la chancellerie adressé aux
parquets une circulaire invitant un
procédé aux qualifications de
l'incrimination de harcèlement sexuel
désormais inexistante en violences
volontaires éventuellement avec
préméditation en harcèlement moral ou en
tentative d'agression sexuelle le 7 juin
j'ai pour ma part adressé une dépêche au
parquet leur demandant de me faire
retour pour le 30
des réquisitions et décision que vous
avez été amené à prendre sur les
procédures en cours
évidemment cette demande concerne des
demandes est personne d information un
personnel et les packs qui ont bien
faire remonter les données techniques et
juridiques qui permettent de saisir ce
que sont devenus les affaires non
définitivement jugés au moment de l'
abrogation commencer par le conseil
constitutionnel avant de vous indiquer
les données sur ces procédures
je voudrais parcourir rapidement
l'évolution des statistiques sur les 20
dernières années
les données les plus fiables dont
dispose le ministère de la justice sont
extraites du casier judiciaire et
concerne les condamnations de 1994 à
2003 le nombre de condamnations pour
harcèlement sexuel s'est établie entre
30 et 40 par an en 1992 des voix se sont
élevées pour prédire que la création du
délit de harcèlement sexuel conduire
elles excessives judiciarisation des
rapports sociaux dans l'entreprise où
disait ces boîtes et ses voix étonnante
peuvent exister des jeux de séduction
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation a rappelé dans un arrêt datant
du 19 janvier 2005 une attitude de
séduction même dénué de taxes ou de
délicatesse ne saurait constituer le
délit de harcèlement sexuel
pas davantage que de simples signaux
professionnelle lancée de façon exprimer
la manifestation d'une inclinaison
judiciarisation excessive n'a donc pas
eu lieu comme vous l'avez constaté vous
même en 2004 le nombre de condamnations
et monte à 63 pour s'établir entre 70 et
85 par un entre 2005 et 2010 il est
probable que cette augmentation commencé
en 2004 aboutissants un doublement 2005
un doublement relatifs à nous sommes à
85 condamnation par année elle lie à
l'extension de la définition du délit
intervenue en 2002 compte tenu de la
durée moyenne de l'instruction entre le
dépôt de la plainte
l'instruction l'audiencement et le
jugement la durée moyenne de cette
instruction jusqu'au jugement est
d'environ 27 mois je parle évidemment du
jugement en première instance
environ la moitié de ces condamnations
ne porte que sur l'infraction de
harcèlement sexuel
l'autre moitié concerne des infractions
connexes pour ces condamnations la peine
d'emprisonnement a été prononcées dont
78% des décisions entre 2005 et 2010 la
très grande majorité de ces peines
d'emprisonnement et est assortie d'un
sursis total des peines d'emprisonnement
totalement partiellement ferme ont été
prononcées dans zéro à quatre cas pas en
pour le seul délit de harcèlement sexuel
la deuxième peine le plus fréquemment
prononcée à titre principal
l amende dont 17% des condamnations ces
peines d'amendés sont très
majoritairement ferme et de menthe et en
moyens de 1000 euros par ailleurs il
convient de relever au moyenne un ter
des condamnations sont prononcées par
les cours d'appel ce qui constitue un
taux d'appel relativement élevé il est
raisonnable de penser que la réalité
sociologique du harcèlement sexuel
tel qu'il est ressenti par les victimes
est telle qu'on attestent les études et
enquêtes d'ailleurs insuffisante n'est
pas sensiblement la traduction juridique
qui lui est donnée à travers ces
quelques chiffres
personne ne peut en effet sérieusement
penser que seules quelques dizaines de
femmes sont harcelées sexuellement en
france aujourd'hui
le ministère de la justice dispose
également de données sur le traitement
des procédures en matière de harcèlement
sexuel
issus des nouveaux dispositifs
informatiques notamment achoppé les
cachots paix est en cours de
généralisation donc ces évaluations ces
évaluations sont partielles depuis 2003
le nombre d'affaires nouvelles
enregistrées au sein des juridictions
sur la qualification de harcèlement
sexuel oscille autour d'un milieu de
procédure part en plus de la moitié
environ 60% de ces procédures font
l'objet d'un classement par l'infraction
car l'infraction ne peut être poursuivi
soit au motif que le délit n'est pas
constitué soit qu'il existe mode un
obstacle juridique aux poursuites comme
la prescription
pour les autres procédures les parquet
privilégie plutôt la poursuite dans plus
de 60% des cas en recourant un peu plus
à l'information judiciaire pour ce
contentieux contre une moyenne générale
11 % que pour le reste des contentieux
alors ce contentieux atteint environ 11
% contre une moyenne générale des autres
contentieux de 3 9 % sont des chiffres
de 2009 entre 20 à 30 % des plaintes
sont placés pour inopportunité la
majeure partie de ces classements se
fondant sur un désistement du plaignant
en suisse environ 30% d'affaires font
l'objet d'une alternative aux poursuites
le plus souvent de rappel à la loi j'en
reviens maintenant aux remontées
d'informations j'ai sollicité des parcs
et sur ce que sont devenus les
procédures concernées depuis le 4 mai
je vous rappelle donc la dépêche de
requalification date du 10 mai et la
circulaire du 7 juin demandant l'état
des réquisitions et des décisions d'une
façon générale les parcs hier pour
procéder à la reconduite à la
requalification chaque fois c'était
possible 130 procédure menée du chef de
harcèlement sexuel ont été signalés à la
direction des affaires criminelles et
des grâces sur 80 enquêtes préliminaires
en cours
si on fait pour le moment l'objet d'un
classement du fait de l'abrogation sur
19 information judiciaire en cours deux
inspections de l'action publique ont été
prononcées et lui qualifications sont
déjà engagés sur cette affaire en cours
d'audience d'audiencement très affaires
pourront être requalifiée quelle affaire
parvenu à l'audience depuis la décision
du conseil constitutionnel ont donné
lieu à une extinction de l'action
publique pour quatre d'entre elles
mais pour les autres les
requalifications ont pu être établis
dans la circulaire d'application du
texte que vous à que le parlement
adoptera et que jabra serait au
procureur de la république des colonnes
de loi aura été adoptée et promulguée
j'entends inciter fortement sur la
nécessité de donner aux fai l'heure
exacte qualification pénale
la précision est l'extension du champ
d'application de l'infraction est sont
telles que ce nouveau délit de
harcèlement sexuel est plus étendue que
dans les précédentes dispositions
cependant il faudra veiller à ce qu'ils
ne soient pas utilisées pour sanctionner
des agissements relevant d'autres
incrimination plus graves notamment
l'agression sexuelle ou le viol comme ce
fut déjà constaté par le passé
je vais vous présenter rapidement le
projet de loi tel qu amendé par la
commission des lois du sénat est d'abord
le projet du gouvernement
le projet déposé par le gouvernement
poursuit trois objectifs donne une
définition du harcèlement sexuel qui
tout en respectant les exigences
constitutionnelles permettent de couvrir
l'ensemble des situations concrètes
repérer ou probables permettre une
répression adaptée à la gravité de ces
agissements cohérente au regard d'autres
infractions sexuelles
ceux qui appliquent la création de
circonstance aggravante réprimer
également de façon cohérente et
exhaustive les discriminations faisant
suite à des harcèlements sexuels
ce qui exige de modifier à la fois le
code du travail et le code pénal une
définition adapté et a élargit donc du
harcèlement sexuel dans le projet du
gouvernement pour exiger cette
définition
le gouvernement s'est inspiré de la
définition du délit tel que rédigé
jusqu'à la loi de 2002 qui a annulé la
définition qui a qui a supprimé la
définition est énoncé simplement
l'infraction de la définition du
harcèlement sexuel finir figurant dans
les directives européennes
cette définition cependant n'a pas été
purement et simplement reprise car les
directives européennes ne sont pas de
nature pénale
et nous avons par ailleurs choisi de
pénaliser des comportements c'est à dire
de nous de retenir des éléments
objectifs et repérable plutôt que nous
en tenir au ressenti de la victime
intime probablement
réel mais qui serait susceptible d'être
contestée au motif justement de cette
subjectivité
nous nous sommes appuyés également sur
les définitions figurant dans les
propositions de loi déposée au sénat et
le projet de loi s'est enfin nourrit du
riche dialogue noué avec les
associations il s'emploie à faire vivre
et faire respecter au quotidien des
droits des femmes
mais nous avons aussi pris très
fortement considération la cinquantaine
d'auditions auquel s'est livré le groupe
du travail du sénat et nous avons par
ailleurs nous mêmes auditionné des
associations des personnalités
qualifiées et des syndicats des
représentants syndicaux parce que nous
savons bien que ces acteurs vont
contribuer à faire vivre la loi aux
côtés des praticiens du droit
il est clairement apparu une définition
unique du harcèlement n'était pas
possible cette unicité but en effet sur
la difficulté de concilier le terme
harcèlement qui dans la langue française
suppose une réitération avec la volonté
largement partagée exprimé aussi très
très largement par vous les sénateurs la
volonté de sanctionner à fait unique dès
lors qu'ils présentent une particule une
particulière gravité pour bien rendre
entente cette dualité
le texte du projet de loi distingue
ainsi de grandes catégories de situation
dans les alinéas 1 et 2 du nouvel
article 222 33 du code pénal le
harcèlement simples et produit par le la
lie les nains et est ainsi constitué par
des comportements imposé répétées qui
présente une connotation sexuelle et
qu'ils soient porte atteinte à la
dignité de la personne en raison de leur
caractère dégradant humiliant soient
créées pour elle un environnement
intimidant hostile ou offensant il n'est
donc plus exiger comme par le passé des
pressions tendant à obtenir une relation
de nature sexuelle
pardon
laure devant la commission des lois
j'avais fait mention d'une réflexion de
la sénatrice virginie klès qui rappelait
que le harcèlement c'est le supplice de
la goutte d'eau puisque c'est souvent
une multitude de petits faits sans
gravité en gravité manifeste en tout cas
mais qui répétait devient insupportable
nous avons utilisé le vocable imposé il
a été choisi après des débats sur non
désirée ou subie le vocable imposait été
choisi parce qu'il existe déjà dans le
code pénal pour l'infraction
d'exhibition sexuelle puisqu'il signifie
que la victime n'a pas consenti aux
actes de l'enseignement qu'elle ne les a
pas désirer mais qu'elle les a subi s'il
appartient la victime de démontrer la
matérialité des faits il ne veut pas
être exigé d'elle qu'elle est démontré
sa réprobation de manière expresse le
juge appréciera au regard du contexte
des déclarations des partis et des
témoins s'il existait ou non un accord
de la victime c'est ce que font
habituellement les juridictions dans les
dossiers de moeurs
la notion d'environnement mentionnés à
l'article 1er ne doit pas être
interprétée comme exigeant que cet
environnement résulte également du
comportement de personnes autres que
l'auteur de l'infraction
en pratique la notion d'environnement
doit être comprise comme faisant
référence aux conditions de vie ou aux
conditions de travail expression qui
figure dans la définition d'autres
d'élus délits prévus par le code pénal
je sais que votre commission encore
travailler sur la notion d'environnement
donc c'est une discussion qui nourrira à
nouveau nos débats tout à l'heure
toutefois l'alinéa 2 de l'article 222 33
prévoit que lorsque les faits prévus à
l'alinéa 1 s'accompagne de telles
pressions
il s'agit d'une deuxième forme de
harcèlement s'apparentant à du chantage
sexuel auquel je mets des guillemets
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un terme
juridique et punis plus sévèrement
c'est pour le projet de loi du
gouvernement bien entendu dans ce cas
les faits sont sanctionnés même s'ils ne
sont pas commis de façon répétée dans
les deux cas il faut souligner que les
fai peuvent être commis par toute
personne et pas seulement par un
supérieur hiérarchique de la victime qui
abuseraient
son autorité la volonté du législateur
de 1992 était de pouvoir incriminé à
fait unique d'une particulière gravité
les débats parlementaires de cette
période
en témoigne mais la rédaction de la loi
qui ne faisait pas référence à cette
gravité n'avait pas permis de transcrire
cette volonté dans la réalité
la difficulté est donc de préciser ce
qui doit être considéré comme un acte
d'une particulière gravité notion qui
bien entendu peut-être relative
le projet de loi propose donc que cette
gravité soit kateri zay par deux
éléments précis et objectifs
un comportement une pression grave
exercée sur la victime par le recours à
des menaces contraintes ordre et c'est
un but c'est le deuxième critère obtenir
une relation sexuelle de nature sexuelle
concrètement il s'agit de sanctionner ce
qui a pu être qualifié en langage
courant de chantage sexuel étant rappelé
encore avec des guillemets quand l'état
du droit
le chantage est une infraction qui ne
couvre pas ce cas de figure il s'agit
donc de comportement lors d'entretiens
d'embauché pour une promotion pour
l'attribution d'une note un diplôme ou
un logement ou en contrepartie de
l'acceptation tout cela en contrepartie
de l'acceptation d'une relation de
nature sexuelle
la preuve évidemment peu en ce domaine
sera portée par tout moyen
le texte issu des travaux de la
commission des lois votre commission des
lois a repris la distinction proposées
par le projet dans les alinéas 1 et 2
tout en la simplifiant dans des
conditions qui améliore qui améliore par
dont la définition du délit et reçoivent
ainsi le plein accord du gouvernement
le e de l'article défini ainsi le
harcèlement simple entre guillemets
comme le fait d'imposer à une personne
de façon répétée des propos comportement
ou tout autre acte à connotation
sexuelle qu'ils soient porte atteinte à
sa dignité en raison de leur caractère
dégradant ou humiliants soient créés à
son égard en environnement intimidant
hostile ou offensant le 2 de l'article
prévoit qu est assimilé au harcèlement
sexuel le fait même nom répéter
d'user d'ordre de menaces de contrainte
ou de toute autre forme de pression
grave dans le but réel ou apparent
d'obtenir mon relation de nature
sexuelle que celle ci sous que celle ci
soit recherché au profit de l'auteur des
faits au profit d'un tiers la définition
du deux nets ainsi plus lié à celle du 1
et elle n'existe pas toujours
toujours de faire répéter cette double
définition permet ainsi de réprimer
toutes les formes de harcèlement sexuel
soit qu'il s'agisse de faire répéter
soit qu'il s'agisse de fait unique mais
particulièrement graves sont ainsi
protégés trois types de victimes celles
qui subissent à plusieurs reprises des
comportements paroles gestes ou autre à
connotation sexuelle et portant atteinte
à leur dignité celle dans les conditions
de vie ou de travail deviennent
insupportables en raison des propos
geste comportements sexistes dont elles
font l'objet
celles qui font l'objet de chantage
sexuel parce que par exemple elle
postule à l'obtention d'un appartement
d'un emploi d'un diplôme ou d'un service
quelconque toutes les situations seront
ainsi couvertes par le droit pénal une
répression adapté aux enchaînements
sexuelle la répression de l'infraction
principale le projet de loi proposé de
réprimer d'un an d'emprisonnement et de
15000 euros damende le harcèlement sein
entre guillemets et de deux ans
d'emprisonnement et 30 mille euros
damende le harcèlement accompagné de
pressions c'est à dire sanction pourle
alinéas 1 et sanctions pour la linea 2
votre commission a proposé d'unifier la
répression en la portant dans les deux
cas à deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30
mille euros damende cette solution
reçoit l'accord du gouvernement dans la
mesure où l'on peut considérer qu un
fait unique peut avoir une gravité des
conséquences pour la victime aussi forte
que la réitération de faits isolés moins
graves et inversement bien entendu et là
il appartiendra au juge d'en faire
l'appréciation création de circonstance
aggravante le gouvernement propose
aggravé les peines du renseignement dans
quatre hypothèses
lorsque les faits sont commis par une
personne qui abusent de l'autorité que
lui confèrent ses fonctions lorsque les
faits sont commis par an et demi sur
mineurs de 15
lorsque les faits sont commis sur une
personne dont la particulière
vulnérabilité due à son âge à une
maladie à une infirmité à une déficience
physique ou psychique ou à un état de
grossesse est apparente ou connue de son
auteur
enfin lorsque les faits sont commis par
plusieurs personnes agissent en qualité
d'auteur ou deux complices dans ces
quatre cas les peines sont portées à 3
ans d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros
d'amendé
ces différentes circonstances
aggravantes sont déjà produits pour le
crime de viol ou les agressions
sexuelles il est ainsi cohérent de les
prévoir en matière de harcèlement sexuel
le dispositif répressif global atteint 6
cohérent et graduées le harcèlement
sexuel est puni de deux ans
d'emprisonnement et de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement s'il est aggravé les
agressions sexuelles je vous le rappelle
sont punis de cinq ans et de 7 ou 10 ans
d'emprisonnement si elles sont aggravées
le viol est puni de 15 ans de réclusion
criminelle ou davantage s'il est à
gravelines répression des
discriminations au delà de la répression
du harcèlement sexuel proprement dit le
gouvernement a estimé indispensable de
sanctionner les discriminations qui
peuvent résulter de ces faits de
harcèlement cette discrimination doivent
être réprimés y compris lorsqu'elle
intervient dans des domaines autres que
les relations de travail et y compris si
elles font suite à un acte unique
cela peut être par exemple le cas d'une
personne qui parce qu'elle a refusé une
proposition de nature sexuelle n'est pas
embauché et licenciés dont tient pas une
promotion ou se voir refuser un logement
ou n'importe quel autre bien ou service
il était donc indispensable de compléter
les articles 225-1 et 225-2 du code
pénal réprimant les discriminations en y
ajoutant un article 225-1 un relatif aux
discriminations intervenants raison de
l'acceptation du reçu par une personne
de subir des agissements de harcèlement
sexuel y compris si ses yeux ces
agissements n'ont pas été commis de
façon répétée certains seront ainsi puni
en application des articles 225 2 à
432,7 du code pénal de trois ans
d'emprisonnement s'ils sont commis par
en particulier
et de cinq ans d'emprisonnement s'ils
sont commis par un agent public ou dans
un lieu accueillant du public ou aux
fins d'en interdire l'accès par exemple
les discothèques entre autres le code du
travail a également été complété par
coordination afin de renvoyer à la
nouvelle définition du harcèlement
sexuel
figurant dans le code pénal et de
prévoir que les discriminations dans le
travail
faisant suite à un affaissement
sexuelles sont pénalement sont
pénalement sanctionné ce qui n'était
plus le cas depuis le 1er janvier 2008
toute la logique du gouvernement et de
lever les obstacles d'un dut à la
dénonciation des faits et au dépôt de
plainte en protégeant la victime et les
témoins les représailles éventuelles
tout faire pour que l'espèce est ce le
plus rapidement possible en effet comme
a pu le souligner la ville de la
commission sociale des affaires sociales
les témoignages reçus montre à quel
point les victimes peuvent être
profondément affecté par le harcèlement
qui provoque perte d'estimé de soi les
fragilités psychologiques et minent leur
capacité de résistance
quelques observations sur la
problématique de la majorité sexuelle
sur laquelle je sais vous avez beaucoup
débattu pour répondre au projet de
modifier la circonstance aggravante de
minorité de 15 ans minorité simple je
vous indique que le gouvernement propose
que la majorité de 15 ans doivent être
une circonstance aggravante du
harcèlement sexuel
votre question est pourquoi cette
circonstance aggravante ne s'applique
pas aux mineurs de 15 à 18 ans question
parfaitement pertinent puisque il est
assez rare que dans les entreprises se
trouvent des mineurs de 15 ans et que la
tranche de minorités concerne
effectivement des jeunes de 15 à 18 ans
dans le code pénal
seule la minorité de 15 ans constitue
une circonstance aggravante
c'est le cas pour le meurtre les
tortures et actes de barbarie
les violences le viol les agressions
sexuelles et d'autres délits ou crimes
ce seuil de 15 ans date de l' ordonnance
du 2 juillet 1945 il était d'abord de
onze ans en 1810 il est passé à 13 ans
puis en en fin du 19e siècle en 1863 un
mineur de plus de 15 ans a le droit
d'avoir des relations sexuelles
librement consentis y compris depuis
1983 avec une personne de même sexe
il en découle que ne sont punissables
que les atteintes sexuelles qui par
définition sont réalisés sous contrainte
commis sur des mineurs de moins de 15
ans car le législateur estime qui n'a
pas tout le discernement pour exprimer
un consentement éclairé
c'est donc pour tenir prendre de ces
matches de cette majorité sexuelle à 15
ans que le législateur lorsqu il aggrave
les peines en raison de la minorité de
la victime fixe également le seuil à 15
ans il semble que la nécessaire
cohérence de notre droit pénal dont j'ai
l'obligation d'être le garant justifie
de conserver ce seuil de 15 ans en
matière de harcèlement sexuel
cela évidemment n'interdira pas aux
juridictions en matière de harcèlement
sexuel comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs
pour les autres infractions d'être en
pratique plus sévère si les faits sont
commis sur mineurs de 15 à 18 ans s'il
s'agit notamment d'un jeune ou d'une
jeune stagiaire dans ce cas
l'aggravation pourra fréquemment venir
de l'abus d'autorité la problématique
vous avez soulevé de la vulnérabilité
économique et social le gouvernement
propose que la sanction soit aggravée
lorsque les faits sont commis sur une
personne dont la particulière
vulnérabilité due à son âge est une
maladie à une infirmité à une déficience
physique ou psychique ou à un état de
grossesse est apparente ou connue de
l'auteur
lors des travaux en commission vous avez
été plusieurs sénateurs et sénatrices a
exprimé le souhait d'y adjoindre la
vulnérabilité économique et social
évidemment on ne peut qu'attendre le
souhait d'assurer une plus grande
protection de nos concitoyens très
nombreux trop nombreux à bénéficier de
faibles revenus a disposé en fait de
faibles revenus de contrats précaires ou
de situations sociales fragiles
bien entendu on pense surtout aux
familles monoparentales cependant je
m'interroge sur la pertinence de confier
au juge le soin de définir le degré
forcément subjectif au moins relatif de
la vulnérabilité sociale en sachant que
cette appréciation peut-être poreuse à
des préjugés idéologiques je me range
donc à la réserve inscrit dans la vie de
votre commission aux affaires sociales
qui indique introduire la notion de
vulnérabilité économique dans le code
pénal serait une innovation et qu'il est
possible que les tribunaux et du mal à
l'appréhender dans un premier temps en
raison de son caractère relatif il
appartiendra en outre à l'accusation de
démontrer que cette vulnérabilité aura
été l'élément déclencheur du passage à
l'acte
ça nous conduit à craindre que ce cette
disposition fragilise en fait la
poursuite et dessert ventre est la
victime
bien entendu cela n'exclut pas notre
obligation de train de combattre
ensemble
cette vulnérabilité sociale et de faire
en sorte que les politiques publiques
économiques et sociales soit de nature à
favoriser une meilleure santé économique
générale il convient de garder à
l'esprit que le conseil constitutionnel
a invalidé le texte précédent pour non
respect du principe de légalité des
délits et des peines qui impose de
définir les crimes et délits en termes
suffisamment claires et précises
il y a donc que lieu de prendre des
précautions et il paraît opportun de
reprendre au maximum des termes qui
existe déjà en droit pénal
c'est en fonction de cet impératif que
le gouvernement était très attentif aux
observations juridique du conseil d'état
qui a émis un avis globalement favorable
sur le texte en conclusion
évidemment ce projet de loi déjà
fortement amélioré par les travaux de
vaud commission commission des lois
commission des affaires sociales et
délégation aux droits des femmes sera et
par les amendements des reporteurs
notamment sera encore enrichi à un juge
et pas les nombreux amendements déposés
le gouvernement est très ouvert à la
discussion et quelle que soit la
provenance des amendements ils seront
examinés avec la plus grande attention
parce que nos travaux préparatoires ont
bien laissé apparaître qu'il y avait un
large consensus sur ce texte
je voudrais pour finir rappeler que si
le harcèlement sexuel ainsi énoncé se
trouve dans notre droit pénal depuis 92
94 les faits le pré existants très
largement en trouve dans une loi du 9
mai 1872 et 1874 et une du 2 novembre
1892 des injonctions faites aux patrons
et aux chefs d'établissements les
invitant à maintenir à maintenir le les
bonnes moeurs
voilà les invitant au maintien des
bonnes moeurs et à l'observation de la
décence publique
alors ce sont des termes extrêmement
paternaliste c'est une conception
vieillotte de la situation suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs que la conception est
tellement tellement évolué depuis
il est intéressant de rappeler qu'il
s'agit de deux textes de lois qui
traitait de du travail de filles et de
garçons mineurs dans l'industrie
je voudrais m'arrêter quelques instants
sur un mouvement social qui a eu lieu au
début du siècle dernier en 1905
c'était à l'image dans une usine de
porcelaine de havilland à limoges en mai
des femmes se sont mis en grève majorité
des salariés étaient des femmes se sont
mises en grève contre contremaître
qu'elle accusait de pratiquer le droit
de cuissage
elles ont raccroché leur mouvement de
grève un mouvement ouvrier qui était
organisée contre les bas salaires et des
licenciements
le fait qu'elle ait introduit une
dimension de dignité de la personne dans
ce mouvement social a augmenté la
la force du mouvement social et son
efficacité mais surtout en fait elles
ont ces femmes en arracher la société à
son mutisme à son aveuglement à sa
pruderie à son hypocrisie pour parler un
peu avec brutalité
elles ont donné une véritable visibilité
sociale aux phénomènes de harcèlement
sexuel dans l'entreprise et elle ainsi
elles ont permis qui évolue à la fois la
loi et les mentalités
ce qui prouve que c'est bien souvent la
probabilité sociale politique féminine
qui permet de faire évoluer le droit
alors je ne méconnais pas les débats qui
ont lieu des débats techniques des
débats juridiques des débats
philosophiques sur ces incriminations
demeurant récente dans notre droit
je les entends sont les récuser tout
d'ailleurs totalement je les entends
lorsqu'elle évoque la privatisation du
procès pénal et le passage de
l'incrimination comme à tête au corps
social vers une prééminence de
l'incrimination comme atteinte à
l'individu et pas seulement c'est à son
corps physique mais également à son
intégrité psychique
mais la question qui est posée est de
savoir comment nous appréhendant des
comportements l'évolution comportement
qui est d'ailleurs une régression très
souvent regard du droit au regard des
libertés individuelles regard de
l'altérité
comment nous appréhendons dans
l'évolution de ces comportements dans la
société parce que en fait nous traitant
de faits d'abus de droit ou d'autorité
nous traitant de souffrance
nous traitons aussi de mutations dans
les relations de travail fondé sur une
conception managériale que nous sommes
en droit et même en deux voire
d'interroger aujourd'hui et cette
conception managériale s'ajoute à la
persistance dans la société à la fois de
clichés et de représentation par
conséquent il est important de
s'interroger sur la réponse que nous
apportons à de telles situations et il
est bon de noter que
le travail que nous accomplissons
aujourd'hui est susceptible de nous de
nous permettre d'avancer sur ce plan
nous sommes dans des sociétés qui cumule
à la fois des technologies extrêmement
sophistiquées et des comportements qui
relève de rapport à kayes it vis-à-vis
de l'autre l'autre féminin ou l'autre
différent ce sont toutes ces
interrogations qui vont nourrir nos
débats j'en suis absolument sûr qu'ils
vont continuer à les irriguer pour notre
part nous serons extrêmement attentifs à
toutes vos observations et à nos
échanges nous acceptons d'être encore
habité par le doute parce que nous
pensons que le doute est un moteur
puissant pour l'action de progrès et
comme l'écrivait stendhal nous affirmons
finalement que l'admission des femmes à
l'égalité parfaite serait la marque la
plus sûre de la civilisation
merci pour votre attention merci merci
madame la ministre
la parole est à madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministre des droits des femmes
et porte parole du gouvernement
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
rendant hommage aux femmes victimes de
harcèlement qui avait trouvé le courage
de défendre leurs droits
un avocat du barreau de paris reprenait
ainsi en 2007 la parole d'une de ces
femmes cela valait la peine finalement
la justice m'a rendu justice
nous étions en 2007 on était loin alors
d'imaginer que cette demande de justice
que cette demande de reconnaissance
d'une souffrance véritable pourrait se
trouver compromise par l'abrogation
d'une loi par le conseil constitutionnel
nous sommes en 2012 et le 4 mai dernier
le conseil constitutionnel a en effet
abrogé avec effet immédiat le délit de
harcèlement sexuel au motif de son
inconstitutionnalité
les premiers mots que je veux avoir
devant vous ce jour ce sont des mots de
soutien pour celles car nous le savons
ce sont les femmes qui sont pour
l'essentiel concerne et des mots de
soutien donc pour celles qui ont vu les
actions qu'elles avaient engagées
s'éteindre brusquement sans recours ou
presque
certes cela a été rappelé la
chancellerie a donné des instructions et
je veux remercier la garde des sceaux de
cela des instructions pour que les faits
puissent être requalifiés et les actions
poursuivies sur d'autres terrains
violences volontaires agression sexuelle
etc
mais on sait bien que dans certains cas
cela n'a pas été possible
où cela n'a pas été reconnue par les
juridictions cette situation de
souffrance sans recours nous oblige elle
oblige les parlementaires que vous êtes
de toute sensibilité elle nous oblige
nous ministres du gouvernement et je
dois le dire
le sénat par sa mobilisation sans
précédent a été à la hauteur de cette
ardente obligation et ce dès le 4 mai
dernier
vous avez tous ou presque dans cet
hémicycle était acteur de cette
mobilisation à la commission des lois
sous l'impulsion de jean-pierre sueur à
la commission des affaires sociales sous
la conduite de madame annie david
à la délégation des droits des femmes
bien sûr avec l'engagement de brigitte
gonthier maurin
cette proposition de loi un groupe de
travail auditionnant dans un temps
absolument record une cinquantaine de
personnes des rapports de grande qualité
de vos commissions et de votre
délégation
c'est un travail immense et je tiens
comme la garde des sceaux a remercié les
trois présidents vos deux rapporteurs
monsieur alain anziani christiane
demontès avec qui nous avons travaillé
en confiance et qui ont fait un travail
remarquable
je salue aussi le climat très consensuel
dans lequel l'ensemble de ce travail a
été conduit et l'esprit de
responsabilité qui a animé les sénateurs
de tous partis
c'est ce travail global auquel le
gouvernement s'est associé au travers du
projet de loi qui nous appartient
aujourd'hui de faire fructifier ensemble
désormais en rétablissant les délits
vers seulement sexuelle censuré mais
aussi en apportant des avancées des
avancées pour répondre à l'attenté des
femmes vous l'avez écrit dans votre
rapport monsieur le rapporteur le
harcèlement sexuel est un fait aux
demeures et longtemps ignorée du code
pénal puis méconnu dans la diversité de
ses expressions
alors de quoi parle-t-on au juste il
existe comme souvent en matière de
violences faites aux femmes
peu d'études peu d'études pour nous
révéler l'ampleur de ces délits et de
ses crimes
c'est un point sur lequel nous aurons un
échange dans l'après midi puisque comme
vous je reconnais évidemment qu'il nous
manque une instance capable de fédérer
les enquêtes de faire des analyses de
guider les pouvoirs publics
il faut donc en l'absence de cette
instance et au plan national
remonter à 2000 et à la grande enquête
nationale sur la violence faite aux
femmes pour avoir quelques éléments
complété par l'étude de la commission
européenne de 1999
d'autres enquêtes évoqué par christiane
taubira ont été faites en 2007 en
seine-saint-denis comme le mentionne le
rapport de la délégation aux droits des
femmes
ces violences mesdames messieurs sont
une réalité importante de notre société
que l'on ne peut ignorer si l'on passe
sur les 45 % de femmes qui déclarent
avoir entendu des blagues sexistes ou
sexuelles au travail et la moitié
d'entre elles de façon répétitive 13 %
des salariés déclarent avoir côtoyé des
personnes ayant eu une attitude
insistante et gênantes et des gestes
déplacés
elles sont neuf pour cent a déclaré
avoir reçu des avances sexuelles non
désirée au cours de l'année autre donnée
intéressante que vous nous avez fait
partager madame gonthier-maurin madame
la présidente
le harcèlement en plus d'être une
souffrance personnelle est un fardeau
collectif il faut aller voir une étude
conduite en israël que vous citez dans
votre rapport et qui évalue dans ce pays
à quelques 250 millions d'euros le coût
annuel de ce délit qui provoque des
missions mutation rupture de carrière
pour les femmes
et pourtant face à cette réalité
la réponse pénale apparaît en décalage
depuis 2005 on le rappeler mille
procédures nouvelles par an sont
enregistrés pour cette infraction
plus de la moitié de ces procédures a
fait l'objet d'un classement sans suite
au motif que l'infraction n'était pas
constituée
la très grande majorité de ces peines
d'emprisonnement est assortie d'un
sursis total
quant aux peines d'amendé elles sont
d'un montant moyen de 1000 euros environ
on le voit la procédure est exigeante
elle demande un investissement personnel
très fort aux victimes que les
associations ont toutes souligné pendant
vos
sion elle est ingrate aussi cette
procédure pour les victimes car les
délais d'instruction sont longs les
preuves sont difficiles à apporter et
puis parce que le délit tel qu'il
résultait de la loi de 2002 ne punissait
que les agissements sollicitant une
contrepartie de faveurs sexuelles
alors même si le délit n'avait pas été
abrogée par le conseil constitutionnel
le 4 mai dernier nous aurions sans doute
dû ouvrir le débat que nous ouvrons
aujourd'hui parce que la question est
grave parce que sans signaux visible
pour considérer le harcèlement sexuel
comme intolérable par notre société on
ne construit pas une société de justice
de respect et d'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
ce débat nous finissons par la voir dans
ce contexte très particulier qui nous
conduit à agir en urgence pour ne pas
laisser de situation d'impunité
s'installer trop longtemps et parce que
la protection de la loi est un droit
fondamental que le président de la
république et le premier ministre nous
ont demandé de rétablir d'urgence
nous en sommes toutes et tous convaincus
dans cette assemblée
mais avec la garde des sceaux nous avons
aussi eu le souci de garantir la
pérennité de ce nouveau droit est de
nous assurer que la loi soit efficace
qu'elle soit appliquée et qu'une
nouvelle question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité ne viennent pas dans
quelques mois
mettre à bas une nouvelle loi désespéré
une nouvelle fois les victimes et les
laisser douter de l'action publique et
de notre engagement à tous c'est parce
que nous souhaitions agir en urgence que
le premier ministre a mis en oeuvre la
procédure accélérée
je veux remercier le président sueur qui
lors de notre audition nous a confirmé
qu'il ne voyait pas là de mauvaise
manière faite au sénat nous sommes
attachés comme lui comme vous au temps
de travail parlementaire autant d'
expertise mais vous l'avez pris le temps
d'expertisé depuis le 4 mai dernier
c'est parce que nous souhaitions combiné
urgence et sécurité juridique que nous
avons également consulté le conseil
d'état pour conforter notre analyse sur
certaines questions sensibles
la réitération
la notion d'environnement l'échelle dès
peines les articulations à construire
entre code pénal et code du travail
urgence donc sécurité juridique mais
aussi concertation c'est un point auquel
je suis très attaché nous avons avec
christiane taubira eu ce souci de
construire un texte en écoutant les
associations en le partageant avec les
partenaires sociaux
dès notre prise de fonction nous avons
travaillé avec les associations et avons
continué à le faire durant l'ensemble de
la préparation de ce texte
je n'ignore pas bien entendu que
certaines d'entre elles s'estiment
encore insatisfaites doute de certaines
notions ou revendiquent les aménagements
plus lourds comme sur les peines le
travail de la commission des lois a déjà
permis de répondre à certaines de ses
attentes et interrogations il nous
faudra aller plus loin dans le travail
d'explication du texte pour lever les
craintes mais la loi parfaite n'existe
pas sans doute pas celle que nous
cherchons à construire avec la
contribution des parlementaires nous la
voulons claire globales efficaces
cette loi devra être ensuite appliquée
c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit et c'est
le sens de la circulaire pénale qui a
évoqué la garde des sceaux tout à
l'heure cette loi sera un signal pour
les femmes victimes pour les auteurs de
harcèlements aussi c'est le sens de la
campagne de communication que nous
mènerons à l'automne en accompagnement
du texte avec michel sapin ministre en
charge du travail nous avons aussi
évoqué ce projet de loi avec les
partenaires sociaux qui sont concernés
et qui s'en sont saisi toutes les
organisations syndicales ont salué le
souci de répondre à l'urgence et leurs
attentes sur ce texte dialogue enfin
avec votre assemblée avec les membres de
vos commissions avec la délégation aux
droits des femmes
je me réjouis que le travail collectif
dans les auditions dans les commissions
et permis d'examiner le projet de loi en
même temps que les propositions de loi
le travail du sénat a permis de fixer
clairement les termes du débat la
question de l'élément
morales et des éléments matériels du
délit les circonstances aggravantes le
débat sur la rétroactivité entre autres
vos travaux nous ont permis aussi de
voir se construire le consensus sur
quelques principes qui nous ont guidés
le premier la nécessité d'une approche
globale intégrant l'application de la
définition du harcèlement sexuel dans
trois champs code pénal bien sûr mais
aussi code du travail et statut général
des fonctionnaires
sur ce dernier point le texte de la
commission a apporté les compléments que
le projet de loi n'avait pu introduire
s'agissant du statut général des
fonctionnaires la pertinence en deuxième
lieu d'un élargissement de la définition
du harcèlement
s'inspirant des directives tout en
conservant l'indispensable précision en
matière pénale
enfin un dernier point sur lequel nous
nous sommes mis d'accord
l'ajustement des peines et le souci de
la stricte définition des circonstances
aggravantes
votre commission a comme l'a dit
christiane taubira enrichi ce texte et
trancher des questions importantes
l'alignement des peines sur deux ans et
30000 euros damende par exemple elle a
aussi simplifié le texte pour le rendre
plus clair encore je souscris à
l'ensemble des éléments qui vous ont été
présentés par la garde des sceaux
ils décrivent bien notre intention les
équilibres que nous avons trouvée tu me
permet très simplement
en ma qualité de ministre en charge des
droits des femmes d'insister peut-être
sur trois points essentiels
le premier c'est que nous avons eu le
souci que vous partagerez bien entendu
qu'aucune situation ne se trouve
désormais laisser en dehors du droit
c'est un point novateur décisif avec
l'abandon de l'exigence de l'obtention
de faveurs sexuelles
des faits qu'il n'était pas réprimé hier
pourront l'être demain je pense aux
situations vécues par certaines femmes
le harcèlement sexuel quotidien que
certaines vivent
et thésée jusqu'à présent c'est madame
tasca qui a trouvé la formule pour
décrire ce climat qui pourrit la vie des
femmes mais ce sera le cas aussi pour ce
que l'on peut appeler communément le
chantage sexuel en une fois dans un
entretien dans gauche dans une demande
de logement nous avons rejoint votre
analyse il y à bien une définition
juridique du chantage dans le code pénal
elle se prêtait mal à notre cas il
valait donc mieux introduire dans ce
texte une définition précise
intégré à la notion même de harcèlement
sexuel j'ai d'ailleurs été sensible je
tiens à vous le dire monsieur le
rapporteur anziani madame la rapporteure
demontès à votre analyse bien distinguer
le harcèlement à connotation sexuelle
est ce qu'on peut appeler comme mieux
communément le chantage sexuel et en
même temps ne pas hiérarchiser entre les
souffrances la souffrance provoquée par
un fait répétitif d'un côté la
souffrance générée par un chantage
sexuel un acte unique de l'autre le
deuxième point essentiel sur lequel je
voulais revenir ces peines aggravées
dans une logique respectueuse de
l'échelle des peines concernant les
atteintes sexuelles aux personnes le
projet de loi permet de conserver une
cohérence globale dans les peines pour
les atteintes sexuelles aux personnes le
nouveau délit avec ces circonstances
aggravantes s'insère dans une échelle de
peine qui va de un an pour l'exhibition
sexuelle à cinq ans pour l'agression
sexuelle
or aggravation est à 15 ans pour le viol
or aggravation nous avons entendu les
critiques concernant notamment le fait
que ces peines serait trop légères est
moindre que celle afférente aux vols de
portables mais la révision globale de
l'échelle des peines sera peut-être une
question que vous aborderez dans cette
mandature avec madame la garde des
sceaux
il nous a semblé que ce n'était pas le
lieu dans ce texte je vous sais sensible
à cette prudence dans cette assemblée
enfin troisième point je voudrais
souligner la nouveauté introduite par le
projet de loi
véritable nouveauté le fait que les
discriminations qui font suite à des
faits de harcèlement sexuel
soit à l'égard de la personne victime de
harcèlement sexuel soit à l'égard d'un
témoin de ces faits ces discriminations
deviennent deviendront grâce à ses
textes également punissable tant au
travers des textes du code pénal que de
ceux du code du travail
s'agissant du code du travail il
s'agissait en réalité de rétablir une
disposition dont la suppression était
involontaire les victimes n'avaient pas
à payer ce prix nous rétablissons donc
les choses au delà de la répression pour
finir l'accompagnement des victimes et
la prévention car la répression n'est
jamais suffisante
d'abord nous devons faire en sorte que
les victimes soit informée sur les
droits sur la nouvelle loi
je mobiliserai les réseaux d'accueil
d'information et d'orientation des
femmes à cette fin c'est là une
préoccupation souligné par la délégation
aux droits des femmes avec qui je
partage plusieurs analyses nous
conduiront aussi un travail sur la
prévention sur les représentations sur
les stéréotypes
nous avons commencé d'ailleurs d'aborder
cette question de la prévention dans le
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
puisque j'ai évoqué la question des
violences au travail avec eux dans la
grande conférence sociale qui s'est
achevée hier
marylise lebranchu ma collègue en charge
de la fonction publique en a fait tout
autant avec les organisations syndicales
de la fonction publique
d'ores et déjà le texte de la commission
a pris en compte certaines des demandes
exprimées sur votre banc sur vauban
pardon
cet automne nous lancerons je le disais
cette campagne de sensibilisation sur
les violences au travail nous la
préparons avec les associations et les
partenaires sociaux
au-delà de cela une autre de mes
collègues au gouvernement a pris la
mesure de cette question il s'agit de
geneviève fioraso ministre en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui a engagé une réflexion sur
les procédures disciplinaires que des
associations nous ont signalé comme
largement insatisfaisante pour traiter
les faits de harcèlement au sein de
l'université
nous travaillerons ensemble sur le sujet
de la prévention de la sensibilisation
dans les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur mais tout cela ne sera rien
sans un travail en profondeur sur les
représentations sur les stéréotypes
mesdames jouhanneau demontès comptiez
morin vous l'avez souligné
chacune il faut évidemment davantage
d'études sur le sujet
davantage de travail davantage de
volonté surtout je n'en manque pas je
conduirai ce combat mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le projet du
gouvernement a été construit avec le
souci d'une approche globale qui
permette d'avoir une réponse pénale
bien sûr mais qui pense en même temps
aux actions concrètes à mener sur le
champ de la prévention et de la lutte
contre les stéréotypes
c'est une première réponse elle sera
suivie d'autres
concernant plus largement le champ des
violences faites aux femmes
nous avons entendu les associations très
attentive pour que la loi soit appliquée
sachez que madame la garde des sceaux et
moi-même y sommes évidemment très
attaché je sais que le travail auquel
vous avez tous contribué ici depuis le
début du mois de mai y contribuera je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à alain anziani rapporteur
de la commission des lois
oui madame madame la présidente
madame la garde des sceaux madame la
ministre
les droits des femmes mes chers
collègues nous sommes les témoins d'une
disparition et d'une disparition
finalement rares la disparition d'une
une infraction et avec cette disparition
d'une infraction nous assistons
également à la disparition de centaines
peut-être de milliers de procédures et
avec la disparition de ces milliers de
procédures et bien nous voyons des
centaines peut-être des milliers de
victimes qui sont plongés dans
l'incompréhension et qui voit s'ajouter
la souffrance judiciaire à la souffrance
n'est du harcèlement sexuel
cette évaporation choquant pour les
victimes étaient pourtant selon nous
inéluctable le conseil constitutionnel
vous l'avez dit madame la garde des
sceaux s'est trouvé confronté à un délit
qui de réforme en réforme aboutit à une
simple tautologie qu'est ce que le
harcèlement sexuel et la dernière loi
répondait le fait de harceler quelqu'un
dans un but d'obtenir des faveurs
sexuelles
évidemment ce n'est pas une définition
qui peut nous convenir c'est même une
définition qui est contraire au principe
de légalité des délits et des peines
inspiré par l'article 8 de la
déclaration de l'homme et du citoyen et
cette exigence d'ailleurs nous avait
déjà été rappelé par le conseil
constitutionnel à l'occasion de cinq
textes sur l'inceste et la définition de
la famille et nous voici donc envoyé
nous législateurs à notre responsabilité
faire des lois claires et précises et ce
sera la première orientation évidemment
de nos travaux et c'est madame la
ministre madame les milices la première
orientation de votre texte la seconde
orientation c'est celle de l'ambition
nous devons appréhender mieux une
infraction qui demeure largement ignorée
je ne répéterai pas ce qui a été
excellent et mendient mais j'ajouterai
que l'harcèlement sexuel au fond des
structures durablement ses victimes elle
est réduit au rang de choses d'objets
deux miroirs des fantasmes et que
pourtant malgré la gravité de ce fait il
est trop souvent confondue avec de la
mauvaise plaisanterie de la vulgarité
machiste voir avec une forme maladroite
de galanterie cette expression nous la
trouvons par exemple dans certaines
décisions de justice je ne rappellerai
pas non plus l'étude d'impact vous
l'avez tout à leur signaler je
retiendrai donc qu'un seul chiffre
aujourd'hui il ya environ mille
procédure par an il n'ya que 75 70 à 80
5 condamnations
alors pourquoi si peu de procédures et
encore moins deux condamnations
la première raison elle est commune à
toutes les infractions sexuelles il est
difficile pour la victime d'une
infraction sexuelle de porter plainte
nous le savons et la deuxième raison
elle tient à la difficulté en la matière
plus quand une autre de rapporter la
preuve puisque en la matière dont le
procès vous avez la parole de l'un c'est
souvent un homme contre la parole de
l'autre
et évidemment la difficulté pour la
victime est considérable pour arriver à
montrer qu'elle était victime d'un
harcèlement
voilà donc notre mission refonder une
incrimination avec ses deux objectifs
d'un côté une loi claire et précise pour
satisfaire les exigences
constitutionnelles et de l'autre
à voir également une loi ambitieuse et
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit nous
disposons de beaucoup d'éléments
d'abord nous disposons de cinq
directives communautaires
nous disposons aussi d'une convention du
conseil de l'europe sur la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
nous disposons de la loi du 27 mai 2008
qui a porté diverses adaptations au
droit communautaire dans la lutte contre
les discriminations nous disposons
de cette proposition de loi du sénat où
je nommerai pas les auteurs et moi je
d'ailleurs dans ce débat on a parfois
entendu dire oui mais que de frénésie au
sénat non que d'intérêts j'ajouterai que
d'intérêts pour justement cette cause
qui mérite amplement d'être défendue
nous disposons il aime également des
travaux du groupe de travail qui a été
présidée par un oeil dany david brigitte
gonthier maurin et jean pierre sueur
d'une étude de législation comparée qui
est tout à fait intéressante des
recommandations de la délégation aux
droits des femmes est bien évidemment de
votre projet de loi mesdames les
ministres qui déjà tient compte de notre
réflexion
alors quels sont les éléments communs
qui se dégage de ces différents travaux
la première évidemment c'est la
nécessité d'une nouvelle définition et
pour répondre aux objections du conseil
constitutionnel cette définition devra
obligatoirement c'est vraiment votre
attention sur ce point sinon nous
risquerions une nouvelle censure
disposer d'élément matériel précis le
projet de loi précise que l'infraction
nécessitera tout d'abord des pressions
répétées sous forme de propos de
comportement ou de tout acte à
connotation sexuelle et que ces
pressions devront ensuite provoqué des
dommages à la victime soit parce que ces
pressions ont porté atteinte à la
dignité de la victime soit parce
qu'elles ont créés à son égard selon les
termes du projet de loi
un environnement intimidant hostile ou
offensant la commission des lois
notamment ce matin à opérer deux
modifications dans cette définition
elle a d'abord préféré je crois qu'à
sont tous largement derrière cet
amendement le terme d'agissements à
celui de comportement c'est un
amendement de diass et puis
pourquoi parce qu'il nous a semblé que
le terme d' agissements étaient plus
précis donc correspondait davantage les
exigences constitutionnelles d'une part
mais quand en même temps c'était aussi
un terme peut-être qu'il facilitait la
preuve a rapporté par les victimes
et puis la deuxième modification elle
est d'une autre nature
la commission des lois ce matin a
préféré renoncer à la notion
d'environnement qui est dans les
directives communautaires avec l'idée
que au profit de la situation
non666 sinon vous me vous me troubler
mais ce matin il ya bien eu un
amendement qui a été qui a été voté
aujourd hui vous ne troublez mais c'est
bien un moment qui a été votée en
considérant que la notion
d'environnement était issu du droit
communautaire et donc en réalité interne
anglo saxons et que ce terme anglo saxon
n'était pas forcément complètement
intelligible par nos auditions en tout
cas moins intelligible 1 au terme qui
est celui d'adaptation de situation -
personnellement voilà voilà la
conclusion la commission des lois
moi personnellement je le dis ici je ne
partage pas cet avis et je soutiens la
notion d'environnement comme j'ai
soutenu depuis le début de ses travaux
pourquoi parce qu'en réalité la notion
d'environnement n'est pas étrangère au
droit français
elle se trouve dans l'accord national
interprofessionnel du 26 mars 2010 sur
le harcèlement au travail
elle se trouve dans cinq des sept
propositions loin l'association
européenne contre les violences faites
aux femmes au travail qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions là
évidemment dans ses réflexions et donc
il me semble qu'elles pouvaient
favoriser un consensus
et quant à savoir si les tribunaux
allait ou non pouvoir l'adapter dans
notre droit français eh bien j'ai
interrogé présent la chambre criminelle
de la cour de cassation qui a considéré
qu'il n'y avait pas de difficulté
majeure d'interprétation
mais bon je évidemment je me rallie à la
position de la commission des lois qui
était exprimé une fois que nous avons
posées cette définition du harcelant du
harcèlement c'est à dire une fois que
nous avons précisé cette forme de
harcèlement
on voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas il reste tout un pan du
harcèlement tout une forme du
harcèlement qui n'est pas couvert par
cette première définition ce point là
étant celui qu on a qualifié avec notre
langue qui était une langue ordinaire de
chantage sexuel pour parler simple c'est
le cas vous avez quelqu'un qui dit à
quelqu'un d'autre
écoute si tu bouges pas avec moi tu
perds ton emploi si tu ne fais pas ce
que je veux alors tu n'auras pas un
logement il fallait nécessairement que
nous arrivions à englober cette
situation nous avions pensé qu'il
fallait utiliser le terme de chantage
sexuel
ce terme a été d'ailleurs dans la
discussion parlementaire de 1992 déjà la
question de l'acte unique avait été
visée par le législateur de 1992 mais le
législateur de 1992 après et notamment
michel sappin avait répondu qui était
garde des sceaux à l'époque aux gens
mais bien entendu qu'il faut intégrer
l'acte unique
mais après tous ces débats et bien après
tous ces débats le légiste avait dit
mais ce n'est pas la peine de le
préciser dans la loi
le prix à payer est simple voilà vingt
ans que devant les tribunaux
la discussion se poursuit pour savoir si
un acte unis est un harcèlement ce qui
évidemment vous l'avez dit madame garde
des sceaux si on nouveaux dictionnaires
ont dit non mais si on regarde la notion
elles mêmes ont dit oui
et donc voilà vingt ans que le débat
évidemment se poursuit et vous avez eu
une formule très intelligente qui
consiste à dire est assimilé au
harcèlement sexuel donc on ne brûle
thalys pas le dictionnaire mais en même
temps on reprend la notion voilà donc
l'état nous avec catherine tasca unis
virginie klès notamment nous
avions souhaité aller plus loin et
mettre la notion de chantage sexuel
la commission des lois ce matin a
considéré que cette notion n'est car si
c'est pas le texte est donc elle ne
figure pas enfin c'est un amendement qui
n'a pas était adopté ce matin je
voudrais dire un mot quand même sur un
point très précis parce que nous sommes
toujours attentionné à poser
observations des uns et des autres est
ce que ce grand 2 du texte va exposer
les victimes à des risques de
requalification de tentative de viol ou
de tentative de d'agressions sexuelles
et harcèlement sexuel
la discussion est ouverte et je
comprends en disant mais regardez
beaupré sont toujours difficiles doit
être fondé une telle question je ne
crois pas pourquoi parce que la
tentative dans le droit français
parfaitement définis et que la tentative
nécessaire nécessite obligatoirement un
début d'exécution et qu'une tentative de
viol par exemple nécessitent un début
d'exécution qui n'a pas pu être arrêté
par son auteur indépendamment de sa
propre volonté de la jurisprudence
nécessite à ce moment là un contact
physique une pression physique et si
nous avons contact physique si nous
avons pressions physiques alors nous
sortons évidemment du harcèlement telle
que nous l'entendons
mais madame la garde des sceaux je vous
remercie tout à l'heure d'avoir ajouté
que pour dissiper toute confusion vous
entendiez publier une instruction une
circulaire en tout cas un document qui
précise clairement qu' il ne faut pas
cette qualification
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs que la
requalification est un mâle judiciaire
assez répandu au delà même des
infractions sexuelles
il faudra un jour évidemment si vous
l'entendez se poser cette question
quelles peines fixées
l'ancien texte punit c'est le
harcèlement sexuel d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 15000 euros
damende le projet de loi proposé de
conserver la même peine pour le délit de
bath mais la porter à deux ans et 30000
euros en cas de chantage sexuel et bien
effectivement
nous avons pensé qu'on n'avait pas à
hiérarchiser la souffrance des victimes
entre d'un côté la victime qui souffre
parce que victime d'un harcèlement par
répétition et de l'autre ses côtés
celles qui souffrent à cause d'un
harcèlement par acte unique nous n'avons
pas et hiérarchisé et donc la commission
des lois a retenu la même peine dans les
deux cas quelle est cette peine madame
la ministre des droits des femmes a
rappelé tout à l'heure qui a un débat
c'est vrai qu' il n'est pas normal
disons le franchement il n'est pas
normal que le vol d'un portable soit
plus sévèrement punis que une infraction
à la personne
mais globalement il n'est pas normal que
dans notre code pénal
l'échelle dès peines soient devenus
aussi incohérente et que les infractions
à la personne puisse être moins punis
puis sept mois punies que les
infractions ou bien voilà c'est le
globalement que la question se pose
est-ce que nous allions de saisir cette
occasion pour remettre à jour l'échelle
des peines
vraiment c'est un travail qui
considérable qui méritera beaucoup
d'attention et donc aujourd'hui ne nous
restons aux propositions de deux ans et
de 30000 euros en cash chantage sexuel
dans toutes les formes de chantage
sexuel
quelles circonstances aggravée said plus
rapide possible
le texan prévoit 4 puni trois ans 45000
euros
premièrement si les faits sont commis
par une personne qui abuse de son
autorité
deuxièmement s'ils sont commis sur un
mineur de 15 ans 3e en 4 particulière
vulnérabilité ou enfin si les faits sont
commis par plusieurs personnes on va
regarder ça avec beaucoup d'attention
tout à l'heure au moment de l'examen des
amendements - encore une fois c'est sur
votre attention sur un point la
cohérence du code pénal
méfions-nous là de ne pas modifier une
petite partie du code pénal si quelques
lignes de code pénal évident et sans
nous poser la question de l'ensemble du
code pénal ça va être le cas par exemple
sur l'âge de 15 ans sur la main une
minorité de 15 ans
la minorité 15 ans a depuis 1945 vous
l'avez rappelé un sens au fond c'est un
sens qui fixe la majorité sexuelle
c'est à dire je reprendrai ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure un adulte
qui a une relation sexuelle avec un
mineur de moins de 15 ans peut faire
l'objet 800 qu'on se pose la question du
consentement du mineur et un adulte qui
a des relations sexuelles avec une
mineur de plus de 15 ans est bien là ne
pourraient être poursuivis que si
l'absence de consentement sexuel du
miller voilà la démarcation et si donc
comme ça à l'occasion d'un amendement
nous remettons en question cet âge de 15
ans vous voyez les conséquences dans
l'ensemble du code pénal et puis nous
aboutirions a quand même quelque chose
qui serait complètement choquant c'est à
dire que le viol sur une mineure de 16
ans ne serait pas une circonstance
aggravante
alors que le harcèlement sexuel sur une
mineure de 16 ans deviendrait une
circonstance aggravante
là aussi un principe de cohérence il
reste dans les circonstances aggravantes
la question de la vulnérabilité
économique et social qui a été écarté
par la commission ce matin je reprendrai
les propos que voilà la commission
anémie défavorable sur l'amendement qui
tendait à ajouter cette notion du niveau
et économique et social dont dans le
code pénal
on voit bien les arguments effectivement
c'est la cohérence globale
la notion de vulnérabilité par ailleurs
n'est pas une vie d'ermite économique et
social
il ya la preuve de la question de
l'arbitraire beaucoup l'arbitrage les
juridictions qui finalement fixeront la
définition de la vulnérabilité
économique et social
on voit bien toutes les contraintes on
voit bien toutes les difficultés
moi même d'ailleurs j'avais pris
position défavorablement par rapport à
cette notion là en même temps je crois
que nous devons rester ouverts
quelqu'un a dit avec beaucoup de
justesse ce matin que au fond
aujourd'hui une personne qui en
situation de vulnérabilité économique et
social et intuitivement nous voyons bien
de quoi il s'agit c'est une victime
toute désignée pour le harcèlement
sexuel et donc il faudra en tenir compte
il ya également un autre amendement et
j'aurai fini qui est l'orientation celle
de l'orientation sexuelle et des
transsexuels l'orientation sexuelle est
une circonstance aggravante pour le viol
et d'une circonstance aggravante pour
les agressions sexuelles
moi je trouverais cohérent qui puisse
également qu'elle puisse également
devenir il c'est qu'on sent sa grave
entre dans le cadre de harcèlement mais
ça n'a pas été l'avis de la commission
des lois de ce matin deux mots quand
même peut-être sur les autres articles
l'article 2 est un article extrêmement
important il traite des discriminations
l'article premier puni le harcèlement
sexuel l'article 2 va punir les
conséquences du harcèlement sexuel
c'est à dire par exemple si une femme
harcelée sexuellement elle va pouvoir
agir compte le fait du harcèlement
sexuel
mais si en plus elle a perdu son emploi
alors elle pourra également agir
du fait de la discrimination qu'il aura
subis et cet article est très important
parce que il permet de viser non
seulement l'auteur de harcèlement sexuel
mais également l'employeur
si par exemple dans une entreprise vous
avez quelqu'un qui fait du harcèlement
sexuel et qui est couvert par son
employeur et que son employeur dire que
finalement cette fille là et nous embête
avec toutes ces histoires dehors eh bien
on pourra punir l'employeur pour le fait
de discrimination et c'est aussi un
article qui va protéger le témoin de
témoins coeur a dit oui moi je suis
témoin ge dénonce les faits de
harcèlement et qu'il se verrait exposé
une sanction disciplinaire
il pourra bénéficier de cette protection
l'article 3 est bien c'est de la
coordination effectivement avec le code
du travail
la commission des lois ce matin à
adopter pour la reproduction intégrale
du texte du code pénal de la même façon
que il a opté pour cette reproduction
intégrale dans le statut de la fonction
publique
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues je crois que grâce à notre
travail collectif nous allons aboutir à
combler vite et bien
ce vide juridique avait suscité la
stupeur des victimes et nous proposons
il me semble noir plus clair et plus
précise avec un choix élargi
d'infractions comme toute loi
ça a été dit tout à l'heure elle
demeurera tributaire de l'interprétation
de juridiction et comme toute loi elles
nous disent
on sera pas de mesures de prévention
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est un homme christiane
demontès rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la présidente mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues
si le rétablissement du délit de
harcèlement sexuel concerne au premier
chef ici au sénat la commission des lois
compétente en matière pénale
bien évidemment notre commission des
affaires sociales ne pouvait pas se
tenir à l'écart de ce débat le
harcèlement sexuel peut se produire ou
le savon dans des circonstances les plus
variés engagement associatif activités
sportives parcours scolaire ou
universitaire relations de voisinage
recherche d'un logement
il faut bien admettre cependant qu'ils
se déroulent souvent dans un cadre
professionnel
que ce soit dans les entreprises privées
ou dans les administrations
c'est ce qui justifie que l'interdiction
du harcèlement sexuel figurent aussi
dans le code du travail et dans le
statut de la fonction publique la
question du harcèlement sexuel entretien
par conséquent des liens étroits avec
des sujets qui te sont au coeur de nos
des préoccupations de la commission des
affaires sociales je pense à la qualité
de vie au travail
je pense à la prévention des risques
psychosociaux et à l'égalité
professionnelle entre les hommes et les
femmes
la décision rendue par le conseil
constitutionnel le 4 mai dernier a
conduit à l'abrogation de l'article du
code pénal qui définit c'est de manière
trop imprécise le délit de harcèlement
sexuel
il en résulte donc un vide juridique il
est ce vous l'avez dit mais dans les
ministres sans protection les victimes
parmi lesquelles on compte une grande
majorité de femmes
il nous appartient donc en tant que
législateur de remédier au plus vite à
cette situation
le sénat a rapidement apporté la preuve
de sa détermination à agir
dell annonce de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel en groupes de travail c
et en place qui a auditionné toutes les
parties intéressées et les discussions
menées en son sein au permis de faire
émerger de nombreux points d'accord
concernant la nouvelle définition du
harcèlement sexuel
dans le même temps cette proposition de
loi ont été déposées par des sénateurs
et sénatrices siégeant sur différents
bancs de notre assemblée ce qui démontre
s'il en était besoin que la lutte contre
le harcèlement sexuel est un objectif
qui transcende les clivages politiques
certains ont regretté que le
gouvernement n'ait pas laisser prospérer
ces initiatives parlementaires et qu'ils
aient préféré déposer un projet de loi
pour ma part je vois surtout dans votre
choix dans ce choix
un signe de la volonté du gouvernement
de se mobiliser contre le harcèlement
sexuel et je me réjouis à cet égard que
deux ministres soient présentes
aujourd'hui pour en soutenir la
discussion le texte du gouvernement
tenait compte mes chers collègues dès
l'origine des réflexions qui ont été
menées au sénat et il a été encore
améliorée par les amendements adoptés
par la commission des lois
de sorte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
le fruit d'un véritable travail conjoint
qui répondent à nos préoccupations
le texte qui nous est soumis nous donne
satisfaction pour plusieurs raisons
premièrement il parvient à concilier
cela a déjà été dit je vais le faire lui
donc deux impératifs qui pouvait
paraître contradictoire au premier abord
une exigence de précision dans la
définition des éléments constitutifs du
délit afin de satisfaire au principe
constitutionnel de l'égalité des délits
et des peines mais aussi l'obligation de
retenir une incrimination suffisamment
large pour couvrir tous les cas de
harcèlement sexuel
le harcèlement consiste généralement en
une succession de gestes propos
comportements qui ne sont pas
nécessairement très graves pris
isolément mais qui peuvent entraîner du
fait de leur répétition des conséquences
dramatiques sur la santé psychique de la
victime
parfois il s'apparente davantage à un
chantage sexuel
par exemple quand un employeur menace
une salariée de la licencier
si elle refuse de céder à ces pressions
le projet de loi et c'est l'un de ses
principaux mérites permettra de réprimer
ces deux types de harcèlement puisse
qu'il retient une double définition du
délit comme madame la garde des sceaux a
déjà eu l'occasion de leur rappeler
deuxième motif de satisfaction le texte
ne fait plus de la recherche de faveurs
sexuelles
l'objectif exclusif du harcèlement les
auditions du groupe de travail ont
montré que les victimes avaient souvent
du mal à prouver que le harceleur
poursuivait cet objectif ce qui explique
que de nombreuses plaintes étaient est
classée sans suite ou et abouti à une
relaxe
l'abandon de cette condition devrait
permettre aux victimes d'obtenir plus
facilement justice il leur suffira entre
guillemets de montrer que le harcèlement
à porter atteinte à leur dignité ou a
créé pour elle un environnement hostile
intimidant offensant pour que le délit
soit constitué
troisième motif de satisfaction le texte
alourdit les peines encourues en cas de
harcèlement sexuel
jusqu'ici la sanction prévue était d'un
an d'emprisonnement et de 15000 euros
d'amendé
il est proposé de la porter à deux ans
d'emprisonnement et à 30000 euros
d'amande et même à trois ans de prison
et à 45000 euros d'amendé en cas de
circonstances aggravantes
cette mesure qui a une vertu pédagogique
évidente devrait exercer un effet
dissuasif quatrième motif de
satisfaction le texte introduit dans le
code pénal
une disposition qui permettra désormais
de réprimer les mesures discriminatoires
dont peuvent faire l'objet les victimes
de harcèlement sexuel
ainsi un employeur qui licencient une
salariée ou qui refusent refusent
d'embaucher une candidate à un
recrutement parce qu'elle aurait résisté
à ses avances pourra être sanctionné
permettez moi mes chers collègues de
m'attarder un instant sur les articles
qui portent sur le code du travail sur
le code du travail applicable à mayotte
et sur le statut de la fonction publique
je voudrais d'abord rappeler qu'il est
indispensable de modifier le code du
travail dans la mesure où il définit
actuellement le harcèlement sexuel dans
les mains
en termes que ceux qui ont été censurées
par le conseil constitutionnel le code
du travail
on verra désormais à la définition et
aux sanctions prévues par le code pénal
ce qui évitera à l'avenir tout risque de
discordance le projet de loi propose
également de corriger une erreur
intervenue lors de la recodification
2008 le code du travail prévoit qu'aucun
salarié aucun candidat au recrutement un
stage ou à une période de formation en
entreprise ne peut être sanctionné
licencié ou faire l'objet d'une mesure
discriminatoire pour avoir subi ou
refusé de subir des agissements de
harcèlement sexuel lors de la
recodification la sanction prévue pour
réprimer ces fêtes discriminatoire a
malencontreusement disparu il est donc
proposé de la rétablir il est également
proposé de compléter la liste des
infractions que l'inspecteur du travail
peut constater en y ajoutant le
harcèlement sexuel et moral
un monde concernant mayotte cette île
vous le savez tous est engagé dans un
processus de départementalisation qui
conduit à aligner progressivement les
règles de droit social qui sont
applicables
avec celles en vigueur en france
métropolitaine
le projet de loi s'inscrit dans cette
perspective
puisqu'il propose que les articles
relatifs au harcèlement sexuel qui
figurent dans le code du travail soit
inséré à l'identique dans le code du
travail applicable à mayotte
concernant enfin la fonction publique le
texte du gouvernement ne prévoyait pas
initialement d'adapter les dispositions
relatives au harcèlement sexuel qui s'y
applique nos deux commissions hutte à
coeur de corriger cette lacune en
modifiant la loi de 1983 portant droits
et obligations des fonctionnaires afin
d'y intégrer la nouvelle définition du
harcèlement sexuel
nous visons par là bien évidemment les
trois fonctions publiques d'état
territoriale et hospitalière
comme je le disais tout à l'heure la
commission des lois a sensiblement
amélioré
je le dis comme ça le texte du
gouvernement elle a adopté plusieurs
amendements de son rapportant à la 11
jan
je veux saluer le travail ici est
retenue la quasi-totalité des
amendements présentés par notre
commission des affaires sociales saisie
pour avis outre des mesures de
coordination nous avons voulu insister
sur l'importance de la prévention et de
la détection du harcèlement sexuel
la loi reconnaît aux délégués du
personnel le pouvoir de saisir
immédiatement l'employeur lorsqu'il
constate une atteinte au droit ou à la
santé des salariés pouvant résulter de
faits de discrimination
nous avons souhaité indiquer
explicitement que les délégués du
personnel peuvent aussi saisir
l'employeur en cas d'atteinte résultant
des faits de harcèlement dans le même
esprit nous avons souhaité souligner que
les services de santé au travail peuvent
conseiller l'employeur en matière de
prévention du harcèlement
cette précision est cohérente avec les
stipulations de l'accord
interprofessionnel conclu par les
partenaires sociaux en 2010 qui a
reconnu que les services de santé au
travail sont des acteurs privilégiés de
la prévention du harcèlement et de la
violence au travail du fait de leur rôle
d'information et de sensibilisation des
salariés des employeurs
en revanche il demeure un point sur
lequel nous n'avons pas été suivi par la
commission des lois et qui concerne les
circonstances aggravantes du harcèlement
sexuel
en effet nous aurions souhaité au niveau
de la commission des affaires sociales
introduire dans le code pénal la notion
de vulnérabilité économique et social
qui figure dans plusieurs propositions
de loi sénatoriale
la commission des lois n'a pas retenu
notre proposition au motif que la notion
de vulnérabilité économique et social
saurait trop subjective
j'entends bien les objections qui ont
été soulevées et je suis sensible à la
nécessité que la loi pénale qui est
d'interprétation stricte soit aussi
précise que possible
néanmoins la commission des affaires
sociales a souhaité présenter cet
amendement en séance publique afin que
nous puissions débattre et entendent
mesdames le ministe la position du
gouvernement
il nous semble en effet que la prise en
compte des inégalités sociales dans
ledroit p
allah est une question de fond qui
mérite que nous en discutions de manière
approfondie enfin je voudrais souligner
que la lutte contre le harcèlement
sexuel et plus largement contre les
violences faites aux femmes appellent la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique globale
dont les mesures pénales que nous
examinons aujourd'hui si elles sont
importantes non sans que l'un des
aspects une des premières mesures à
adopter pourrait être la création d'un
observatoire qui nous permettrait de
disposer enfin de données fiables et
actualisées
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des propositions
que formulent la délégation aux droits
des femmes et je pense que madame la
présidente va en parler et nous la
soutenons totalement dès l'école les
jeunes devraient être davantage
sensibilisés à la question de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes ce qui
suppose de mener un travail patient de
déconstruction des stéréotypes afin que
garçons et filles ne se voit plus
attribué à l'avance des rôles déterminé
dans le monde du travail
un effort de formation et de
sensibilisation doit être engagée de
manière à ce que les représentants du
personnel
les délégués syndicaux les médecins du
travail les personnels d'encadrement
deviennent tous acteurs de la prévention
et de la détection du harcèlement enfin
cette politique globale doit comporter
un volet consacré à l'accompagnement des
victimes
accompagnement dans les procédures
judiciaires et il faut saluer ici le
travail formidable accompli par les
associations accompagnement
psychologique également ce qui suppose
le suivi soit assurée par des
professionnels formés
présent sur l'ensemble du territoire
plusieurs membres de notre commission se
sont notamment ému du sort réservé aux
victimes qui se grouille trouve
dépourvue de tout recours mais je pense
que ça va être à nouveau dit du fait de
l'abrogation de la loi au moment où elle
était engagée dans des procédures
judiciaires dans la tente
madame mesdames les ministres de la mise
en oeuvre de cette poule
éthique globale et je m'adresse
particulièrement madame la ministre des
droits des femmes
l'urgence reste bien sûr de combler le
vide juridique créée par la décision du
conseil constitutionnel
c'est pourquoi la commission des
affaires sociales vous invite à
approuver ce projet de loi relatif au
harcèlement sexuel qui permettra de
réprimer efficacement ce délit d'aider
les victimes à faire valoir leurs droits
et de dissuader je l'espère des
harceleurs des harceleurs potentiel de
passer à l'acte je vous remercie
merci madame demontès la parole et à
notre collègue brigitte gonthier-maurin
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances
entre les hommes et les femmes
madame la présidente
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues l'abrogation par le conseil
constitutionnel de la disposition pénale
relatives au délit de harcèlement sexuel
a créé dans notre droit pénal à vide
juridique choquant ce vide
nous devons le combler au plus vite pour
ne pas laisser sans protection des
victimes de telles violences et pour ne
pas envoyer un message d'impunité au
harceleur la constitution d'un groupe de
travail commun nous a permis à travers
un large programme d'audition ça a été
dit de mieux prendre la mesure de la
réalité du harcèlement sexuel des
difficultés que pose sa répression et de
dresser le cahier des charges d'une
nouvelle définition du délit qui soit à
la fois conforme aux exigences
constitutionnelles de clarté de la loi
est plus protectrice pour les victimes
nous pouvons en attendre une
amélioration de la réponse pénale n'est
la lutte contre ce fléau social que
constitue le harcèlement sexuel ne peut
se limiter à son volet répressif
aussi notre délégation insiste-t-elle
également sur la nécessité d'une
politique d'information et de prévention
parce qu'on a longtemps sous-estimé son
impact sur les victimes
le harcèlement sexuel reste un phénomène
peu étudiée est sous-évaluée l' enquête
nationale sur les violences envers les
femmes réalisé en 2000 nous en a donné
un premier aperçu
mais cette étude a maintenant plus de 10
ans et des actes d enquête ponctuelles
comme celle réalisée en 2007 en seine
saint denis ont montré que les violences
sexuelles étaient sans doute plus
fréquente encore aux particuliers dans
le monde du travail
il est nécessaire de mieux en
appréhender la réalité pour guider les
actions de prévention et évaluer les
politiques publiques
c'est pourquoi nos deux premières
recommandations portent respectivement
sur la réalisation d'une nouvelle
enquête sur les violences faites aux
femmes en france sur la création d'un
observatoire national des violences
envers les femmes
celui ci n'aurait pas seulement pour
vocation de réaliser des études ne
pourrait également à l'image de
l'observatoire des violences de
seine-saint-denis constituer une
plateforme de collaboration entre les
acteurs engagés dans la lutte contre les
violences
cet observatoire serait également le
correspondant naturel des observatoires
locaux
vous nous avez indiqué madame la
ministre des droits des femmes au cours
de votre audition le 26 juin dernier
l'accueil favorable que vous réserviez à
titre personnel à ces deux
recommandations
peut-être pour vous nous indiquez les
engagements que le gouvernement peut
aujourd'hui prendre et à quelle échéance
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de la de
l'amendement que j'ai déposé voilà donc
pour l'examen en séance publique du
projet de loi sur le harcèlement sexuel
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire
les tranches d'informations le journal
de 19h avec michel grossiord et le
journal de 22 heures avec sonia mabrouk
très bonne soirée sur la chaîne
parlementaire